Aujourd'hui, nous allons pêcher à l'aimant dans un port du Canal Du Midi
En général, les gens y font tomber toutes sortes de choses, souvent des outils
Mais aussi parfois des objets insolites
On va voir ce qu'on y trouve
Ici il y a quelque chose d'assez lourd, comme une corde
On va voir
On a un leurre de pêche
Oh ! Des lunettes
De vues
Attend, je vais les essayer quand même
Je pense que la branche a cassé, du coup elles sont tombées
Données moi ça
Ah mais c'est une monture pour vieille personne
Appelle moi Professeur Ledoux
J'ai trouvé la branche de la lunette
Regardes
Ce n'est pas un cadenas, c'est un taille crayon ancien
Oh ! C'est marrant
On dirait un cadena
Il est lourd
Sympa
Oh la chance !
Je te bat en nombre d'outils
Ouais
Est-ce que c'est de la marque ?
Je ne pense pas
Plein d'outils !
Une clef à pipe et une cuillère
Comme il y a des prises électrique, il a surement plus d'emplacement permanents de péniches
Peut être un peu plus de potentiel
Ah oui un truc
On va essayer de le récupérer quand même
C'est un gilet on dirait
Oh, plusieurs choses
Police Nationale recrutement
Regardes
Recrutement, ce n'est pas un vrai badge de Police
C'est plus une publicité
"Accessoire de haute visibilité conçu pour une utilisation professionnelle"
Cet accessoire de visibilité ne doit pas être modifié, remplacé ou souillé ou endommagé
Il est conçu pour signaler la présence d'un utilisateur visuellement
Quand il est éclairé par des phares de véhicules, sur des routes sombres
C'est un truc de la police !
C'est génial
Je vais le mettre, je vais recruter pour la police nationale
Bon, tu nous a pêché quoi là ?
Un petit polo
Ce n'est pas le polo crocodile
On vous met le lien Ebay dans le lien de la vidéo
Ouais ! Encore un tournevis
Cruciforme cette fois
Le troisième en vingt minutes
Tu es content Rasta ? Il y a ta sœur
Regardes ça, regardes ça !
Un anti vole ?
Ouais
Aussi une fourchette
Qui est en très bon état
Ca fait toujours plaisir
Un anti vole comme ça, autant ne pas avoir d'anti vole
Il a dû tomber, il est encore fermé
On se décale un peu
On va aller de l'autre côté du pont, juste là
On va voir ce que l'on va trouver
Bon, il n'arrête pas de pêcher des couverts et il m'a dit qu'il aller les mettre dans le lave vaisselle
Là il était à deux doigts de tomber dans le canal
Ce qu'il ne sait pas, c'est que je vais faire la découverte de la journée maintenant
Il ne le sait pas encore
Je vais trouver un IPhone avec la vidéo de Pêcheur de Trésors en train de tourner
Un morceau de marteau
Il n'y a que le bout ...
Alors, qu'est ce qu'on a ?
Regardes
Voilà !
Voilà, c'est ça qu'on veut !
Des ciseaux
En bon état
Une fourchette, en bon état
Un couteau rond, en bon état
Le marteau, il n'y a que la tête
Encore une fourchette et un couteau
C'est une dinguerie aujourd'hui
Une fourchette
Non c'est une cuillère, je confond
J'ai un truc là
J'ai quelque chose
Il a un anneau !
C'est tiercé gagnant
Piquet avec anneau
Parfait
Comment vous allez les deux petits ?
Ils ont chaud
Il y a eu un drôle de bruit en arrivant en bas
C'est un peu lourd
Un piquet de péniche, non ?
Il est coincé dans le bord
Ouais ! Il n'est pas beau ?
Celui là est beau, oui
Il est lourd en plus
Je l'ai senti au dernier moment
J'ai fait mieux, il est plus joli le mien, regarde comme il est en bon état
Ouais mais il n'a pas l'anneau
Encore !
Un couteau rond
J'ai eu quelque chose
Ce n'est pas un piquet ça
Oh, il y a une corde
Elle n'est pas très grande
Ca a lâché ?
Peut être une racine
Je ne sais pas si c'était aimanté ou juste une racine
Je sent peut être quelque chose
Ah oui, oui, il y a vraiment un truc
Bien vu François
Viens Quentin il faut être trois
Ca tient bien
On est tombé sur quelque chose de très gros et bien dans la vase surtout
On va aller chercher le treuil
On va sortir ce qu'il y a là dedans
C'est lourd
Il me tarde de voir les bulles
C'est lourd pour nos petits bras
Faites vos pronostiques en commentaires
C'est difficile à dire, peut être un vélo
Ouais un vélo serait le plus logique
Ca peut aussi être un barbecue
On a déjà fait un Hamac aussi en fer
Ca bulle
J'ai l'impression que ça vient même
On aurait dû tirer d'un face dès le début
Ca vient
Laisses faire les hommes forts
Il faut y aller à plusieurs quand même
Pas possible, ce n'est pas un vélo
Il est énorme sinon
Ah ben si
Ah ouais mais attend, faut le tremper  là
Il n'est pas en si mauvais état
Conservé par la vase
"Il n'est pas en si mauvais état"
C'est rare qu'il y ait tous les rayons
A l'avant ils n'y sont pas tous
Je pense que tu pourrais le tester
Il y a encore la chaîne
Je ne sais pas
Elle est à l'intérieur
Il marche, il marche
Je le test
Il faudrait nettoyer ça
Oh pas besoin, tu as le short de pêche
Dommage que j'ai arraché le guidon
Ca va être moins pratique
Allé, jete le à l'eau
Non !
Bon, je vais le repêcher maintenant
Ah ! J'ai quelque chose
C'est quoi ?
C'est le vélo de François, c'est lui qui l'a repéré
En plus il n'y a pas besoin des deux mains, on peut envoyer des textos avec l'autre
Bon, je le test ?
Vas-y
La selle n'est pas droite
Pas grave ça
Je pense que la selle pas droite, c'est un détail pour le coup
Tu veux que je t'aide pour démarrer ?
Ouais
Ah, c'est froid !
Mais pas là !
Il n'est pas bon
Il n'a pas de direction
Ca marche !
Aujourd'hui on est sur un spot magnifique
Très prometteur qui nous a été conseillé par un abonné
Un grand merci à toi, tu te reconnaîtra
On a réussi à se faufiler un chemin, ce n'était pas facile d'accès
Là on a déjà quelque chose
Premier lancé
Les eaux sont inquiétante, c'est vraiment noir
On a prit la disqueuse ou pas ?
Non, je ne pense pas
Ca rentre quand même
Oui ça rentre
C'est léger
Allé c'est parti, deuxième lancé !
Regardes, un vieux morceau de ferraille
Plutôt propre pour l'instant
Un bois, il y a plein de bois
Ah si !
Elle est vide
Vas à l'ombre Rasta
Rasta ! T'es à l'ombre, c'est bien
J'ai enfin quelque chose, j'ai l'impression que tout est à  gauche, où ça bulle
On va essayer de tirer vers là alors
C'est peut être une caisse en fer de magasin
Le bord nous gène
C'est le problème de ces carrières
Ce n'est pas très accessible
C'est bon signe mon petit
Tu t'en fou si elle tombe, elle est vide, rien à perdre
Non, je ne m'en fou pas, sinon je ne ferais pas ce métier
Si c'est vide, c'est nul
Non, c'est pas mal
Elle est en bon état en plus
Je vais essayer là bas alors
Elle est super vieille
Elle est émaillée
Ah oui, c'est sympa
C'est vrai que c'est vieux
J'ai besoin de toi
Tu nous a trouvé quoi de beau ?
Un cendrier, chromé
Il accroche bien, il y a des inscriptions ?
Ca vient
Compliqué à remonter là par contre
Il faudra treuiller grâce à l'arbre
Alors, tu paris sur quoi ?
C'est peut être juste un cadre de moto
Oui un cadre je pense
Il vient mais je ne me voit pas le sortir là
Si, si, si
Je veux bien un coup de main
Ouais c'est un peu lourd, un gros cadre
Peut être que c'est un charriot aussi
Il n'y a pas de supermarché à côté je crois
Je ne sais pas
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ces bâtiments ?
Oui
On se croirait dans un film de zombie
En tout cas les contenaires sont flambants neufs
Mystérieux
Viens m'aider
Il va bientôt retomber je pense
On ne voit pas ce que c'est
Il faut aller regarder avant que ça lâche
C'est un charriot je crois
Il est plus ou moins bloqué, tires ton aimant
Il a une bête sur la tête
Il se gratte
Attend, non, non, non … mais pourquoi tu as fait ça ?
C'est bon, là je l'ai
Là je peux y arriver
J'ai réussi !
C'est bon ! J'ai réussi !
J'abandonne…
On était bon, il ne fallait plus bouger
Voilà
Allé, c'est parti
Il y a de la chiasse là, fais gaffe
Faut rouler en plein dedans
Alors ?
J'ai une grappe de plein de choses
C'est quoi ça ?
J'espère qu'il y a au moins une chose bien là dedans
C'est pas un morceau de moto ça ?
Non pas sûr
C'est un des endroits les plus sales que l'on ait fait
Oui à cause de la vase et des petits morceaux aimantés
On a pas encore trouvé de gros morceaux
ça c'est quoi ?
je ne vois pas ce que ça peut-être
Peut-être un morceau de coffre fort ?
T'as trouvé un copain pour Rasta ?
rasta viens voir
Il ne le voit pas
Voilà le petit ragondin
Sacré Ragondin
Au début je pensais que c'était Rasta qui nageait
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Tu as loupé le ragondin
Allez on va tester cet endroit de la carrière
On prend le deuxième aimant parce que là il y a un gros morceau
C'est de ce côté ?
je suis dessus aussi
Ah quand même au moins ça !
On se disait justement que c'était étrange de ne pas en trouver ici
Oui au moins un
ce n'est pas une mauvaise journée alors
C'est une journée cadre de scooter
C'était certain d'en trouver au moins un ici
Il n'est pas si vieux
Même si c'est difficile à dire
Ce deuxième endroit réserve des surprises, on a autre chose
Oula, c'est juste du grillage ?
Ouais c'est un piquet d'angle
C'est marrant on pourra en faire une antenne
Ok c'était pas un cadre de scooter
On va finir par le nettoyer cet endroit
A force d'enlever tous les petits morceaux
Alors c'est quoi du coup ?
E.T téléphone maison
Non c'est Wall-E !
On va mettre une photo de lui
Wall-E !!!!
Bizarre
Oh non Baptiste !
t'as qu'à pas jeter sur mon aimant
Ma qué cono !
Cretino
Oh oh
Oui oui oui
Moi aussi je pense avoir quelque chose
Alors voyons voir ce que c'est
je paris sur un autre cadre de moto
J'ai besoin du second aimant là
Juste en bas
J'ai remonté un arbre
Là t'es dessus
il est brave ce chien
Ouais il est tranquille il a l'habitude
Il a chaud par contre
Les miens sont en bas, j'en ai trois
C'est notre mascotte
c'est ça
Vous avez vu passer les miens ?
De chiens ?
Euh non
C'est un sac poubelle il y a peut-être des choses à l'intérieur
Avant je faisais du curage de fossés
Ah ouais ?
Vous deviez trouver des choses aussi ?
Il y avait des choses intéressantes parfois ?
Euuuuuuh
Rarement ?
Des mallettes mais vides
Ah ouais
Mais non rien d'intéressant
Ouais rien de fou
Des sacs comme ça oui et des bouts de chèvres découpées
Ah oui ...
Là il y a une assiette
En plastique oui
La bouteille doit venir du sac aussi
Je pense que c'est une poubelle
Des fois les sacs noris ça fait peur
Ouais pour les animaux morts c'est pas top
On en trouve rarement dans l'eau nous au final
Bizarrement
je vérifie quand même s'il n'y a pas autre chose
Un verre je crois
Oui un bocal
C'est toujours du plastique en moins dans l'eau
Tu ne m'as toujours pas aidé pour l'objet ici
Allez
C'est une chaise
C'est ça en moins dans l'eau
Aie moi regarde
ça brille
Ah c'est un pare choc
Il est très vieux celui-là
Il est énorme !
ça vient d'un camion ou quoi ?
Non ça vient des voitures du style de la 403
ça vient vraiment d'une voiture ancienne
Ah oui
Bon ben sympa
ça montre qu'à l'époque ils faisaient de la bonne ferraille
A part le fait que le chrome a disparu, il est encore en bon état
Encore une fois bon courage
Merci bonne journée
Et bien aujourd'hui on a fouillé deux lieux insolites
Pas de découvertes incroyables
N'est-ce pas ?
Ouais voilà, ça fera quand même son petit poids en ferraille
On est content et on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant
Et oui c'est comme ça que ça marche chez Pêcheur de Trésors
Pendant ce temps Rasta
Est en détente, à son habitude
Il a un peu de vase dessus quand même
Oh non il a aussi des boules de plantes